has this person lied to me that when
they tell me they have a seizure the
first thing I think of are you lying
again and it turns out to be true yeah
how many times has he lied to me because
if it was the first time you probably
would be all are you okay I would have
any [ __ ] concerned but the first
thing I did was I I don't believe that
[ __ ] and then my partner found out that
he lied [ __ ] called his sister his
sister was like no our mom's in Korea
what the [ __ ] guy what the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] at one time this guy he was
working for me he he lied about having a
multiple personality disorder and all
everybody in the room was like oh no I
feel so bad and I was like really tell
me how he goes oh man in high school
yeah I already could tell this was
already stretching his lie he's like in
high school my friend she was sexually
assaulted and I said tell me who the
[ __ ] did this to you and then I just
woke up and I was on his driveway and it
was blood everywhere oh my god and then
what does he say and in the whole the
whole room is like captivated right
there like oh man you really got that
guy and I'm all like you guys are
believe in this [ __ ] right now he was
like there was blood everywhere there
was police I assaulted a man because I
had to do it
he's a [ __ ] hero right and I'm like
well I'm looking at this guy and I'm
like you never [ __ ] beat anybody in
your life you lying sack of [ __ ] and I
caught you lying and creating stories so
many times in the past like it's not my
god and I was like really there was a
police there and I'm like annual
assaulted someone right um
so where's the police report oh no no no
like they let me go because they told
him the story I was like they let you go
for assaulting a man and beating him
[ __ ] bloody you you you not only
trespassed on his property you went to
his door opened up the door I don't
remember I blacked out and you almost
killed him and I was like so you there
was blood everywhere you [ __ ] this guy
up and there was no police report there
was no arrest
there was no charges pressed against you
and I was and in there looking at me
like I'm the [ __ ] for pressing this
guy to answer and I'm
you gotta put pressure on a liar this
guy's a lying sack of [ __ ] he's right
now trying to manipulate the whole
entire room making everybody feel sorry
for his ass like he has a mental
disorder
he's the mental disorder that he has
he's a sociopath lying to everybody yeah
he's a [ __ ] lying sack of [ __ ] and
I'm sitting there and I'm like how
[ __ ] dare you manipulate the feelings
of everyone's compassion towards you
right now I was like you lying [ __ ]
sack of [ __ ] it was so funny because
just thought I was such a mean human
being yeah because she witnessed me
pressuring this [ __ ] before because
one time we had a meeting and he was
talking about a situation with with with
one of his ex-girlfriend's and I know
his ex-girlfriend and he was complaining
about how he just does dis and that for
her and from from what I heard is that
he was a complete [ __ ] thirsty
stalker that did not let go after the
fact that they broke up so in his mind
he's just this gentleman that just keeps
giving right and she's just so like yeah
yeah she's so like not appreciative of
all of his [ __ ] so jess was in the
meeting and I was sitting there and I
was like that's [ __ ] complete
[ __ ] like it hauled his ass out and
I was like you're a [ __ ] narcissist
right you think the whole world revolves
around you I was like you need to quit
that [ __ ] [ __ ] and you do stop you
and goddamn stalker I was like you need
to stop stalking your [ __ ] ex because
I'm not gonna allow that [ __ ] at my
company yeah and then I was like you are
no longer allowed to come between the
hours of when your ex is here or
whatever whatever this was like years
ago right and and so at this point I'm
lecturing his ass and then just turns
around she's like you're so [ __ ] mean
and I'm all like look you're gonna
understand who this human being is
whether it's in a couple of months or
later and you're gonna understand why I
speak to him this way yeah and it's like
on the surface it seems [ __ ] up that I
even talked to an individual this way
but you'll see why and then later she
was like okay I get it I get it
so everybody in that room believed that
he assaulted somebody on somebody else's
property almost killed him and the cops
do anything they were captivated by his
[ __ ] story dude I was like cuz if
he's gonna lie that's a pretty bad lie
that has never ever ever ever happened
in the history of man ever dude this
[ __ ] told me he was a 10th
degree black belt in martial arts this
boot and I brought one of my martial
artists buddies around and we all
[ __ ] smart and you know what [ __ ]
dojo did you go to you lying sack of
[ __ ] you're not a temp degree black belt
you have any idea how old you have to be
to be a temp to be black belt it's a
long well I don't know ma I'm speaking
I'm tech mando yeah it takes a long time
no he was a [ __ ] 10th degree black
belt and he doesn't even know how to
[ __ ] kick an apple off of someone's
head oh you're tipping me black but you
get a [ __ ] ruby red apple put it on
your head I know I do it [ __ ]
he's a lying sack of [ __ ] dude
and I don't know man it's just when I
just can't take [ __ ] right so like
when I catch people off of their [ __ ]
and I roast them I just go in and in and
in until they stop lying around me or
whatever it is um and when people see
that they're gonna they think I'm such a
bad guy and I'm like I'm protecting you
you [ __ ] like it'd be a little
smarter about that [ __ ] people yeah it's
so funny to it you know what the thing
about fighting is - if you did it for
that long it doesn't really go away when
I was 270 pounds I could still do it
clean ass spinning heel kick yeah I mean
I remember you came to San Diego yeah
yeah yeah I haven't kicked in ages and
we were kicking bags and yeah and our
buddy Noah was surprised or like David
could [ __ ] kick man yeah I did Tech
one though for like [ __ ] eight
something years like it doesn't go away
like like a tenth the Green Bank no I
was a red belt stripe me get to the
black was that one before the black it
was one before the black I actually uh
I caught the flu or I [ __ ] my [ __ ] up I
can't remember which one it is anymore
but at that time if you wanted to get a
black belt your Saba knee the your table
name which is your master from Korea had
to bring his master to come over to test
you to get a black ball so that's a
legit school man it was a legit legit
school so I had to wait another year to
get a black
so I I never stayed for another year so
I just was a red belt stripe and I got
another stripe and that was about it so
I didn't I didn't get to get my black
belt but before a ridiculous man it's
funny like you got to see through people
I woke up as what they are and how I
said I woke up there was blood
everywhere
[Laughter]
I looked at the faces of the co-workers
they're just they were like captivated
like I can't believe it they were scared
man they're like am I am I in a meeting
with a psychopath and I'm thinking like
this guy is a little [ __ ] she's a lying
sack of [ __ ] but he's never
I've been around killers I've been
around people that are [ __ ] not like
and this guy is a wannabe dude he's
never done [ __ ] ever dawg
I got put into a back of a cop car
because I was around a group of people
that were jumping people outside of a
bowling alley so guilty by association
exactly so how did you not get arrested
for [ __ ] beating the [ __ ] out of
somebody exactly what the [ __ ] are you
talk and I was a youth minister I know
police report nothing the [ __ ] are you
talking about it makes no sense I know
dude you could catch people in their
lies so easily man that's such that's
that literally means that he has never
been around anybody who's got [ __ ] up
in their whole life or he has never
dealt with the cops made that [ __ ] up in
front of me and I'm like I can't believe
you're lying to me cops are not that
nice yeah especially when it comes to
violence like that's that's some
[ __ ] dude that this will tell me
that he he was like once I told him yeah
I lost it because he sexually assaulted
my friend oh you had a great speech too
huh they uh they let me slide I'm like
shut down like they're giving him five
high five like oh yeah go hero
thanks a lot hero and the [ __ ] the
American flag comes down is a movie
that's oh [ __ ] off it's not even like
that in the movies when you assault
somebody they get arrested no matter
what exactly so he even did it that was
so funny that when he threw his fist
I caught it midair I spun him in 360
he'll and us back a [ __ ] powder dust
came out like [ __ ] out of your guy
that's hella smile illusion
he kept I mean cuz man this wasn't the
first time he's lied to me in my face
and other people I blacked out and I
woke up there was so much blood I told
him shut the [ __ ] up that's the craziest
[ __ ] I've ever heard in my life
right I mean we we've had some it's
eccentric people in our group and I'm
not just saying like JK but in our other
businesses too like we just had a lot of
interesting people and that's the other
side of business that they don't tell
you about is the crazy [ __ ]
that you attract do some people can lie
really well to that
oh yeah and you just you kind of get
caught up into the persona that they're
creating and you're like yo this is a
really good guy and then when you start
working with them you find out through
their behaviors to the co-workers that
tattle on them like oh [ __ ] this person
is a [ __ ] psychopath oh yeah there
are people who you know oK we've seen
this as employees before like managers
that get the job because they kiss
[ __ ] ass up to the top dogs mm-hm
but when it